[Music]
is
fresh off the stage why no no still
singing I Love It how'd it feel out
there you and Ashley poured your hearts
out I left Earth uh sometimes it happens
and you look forward to when it happens
I don't remember anything it's um you're
suspended you're not really your feet
are planted on the ground but you're
suspended Ashley was singing your
Praises on the red carpet to me just
absolutely adores you what is it about
Ashley that you were like yes I will
absolutely share the stage he doesn't
mind being perfectly imperfect
she's not one of those people that
you're around and you feel there's this
uptight uh agenda to be something that
you're not Ashley is who Ashley is and
she tells you her deepest darkest
moments of whether it's a self-doubt
moment or oh that really sucked or well
I'll never be that but she's real speak
of the devil she is right here speaking
of the ass
she was just singing your praises
jinxing whatever she wants now listen to
it
how did it feel on stage you two really
rocked it out I told her we were we were
spended I think I left I told her I said
I left Earth something blacked out how
long how'd it go she says I don't
remember
we were all around the TV and we were
like adrenaline is shooting as fast
two superstars out there you had a very
sweet moment you pointed to this guy
[Music]
oh
in that moment what was going through
your mind well it's a year it's an
anniversary and we all have
anniversaries I'm not terminally unique
we all have something that we look at
and go what the hell
what's going on I don't understand and
that was my I don't understand and I I
went back and forth between hitting a
really high note and being a diva or
saying what was on my heart and it took
over and so here we are that's what you
told me you were gonna do on the red
carpet you said you were going to speak
from your heart and offer support to
others and that's what you're doing I'm
gonna try to do that because I want to
help people
it's like look at my face look at this
face if you're having a crappy day and
just think if I can do it so can you
because it's not easy a Pillar of
Strength right here I don't know about
strength but I'm showing up regardless
stuff all the time she don't even know
she's doing it I don't know I'm just
doing it you two are so beautiful I know
you both have another performance after
this too so I know you guys got to get
ready but thank you very very busy
you're very busy well we go be fabulous
I don't know what to say come on let's
go do something I love you
please
[Music]